qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté je
vais mettre au voit mes chers collègues
l'article 3 qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté à l'article 4 un amendement
rectifi il y a deux amendements de de
suppression le premier donc le 720
rectifié madame
swiis merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement vise à supprimer l'article 4
du projet de loi cet article concerne la
clause de sauvegarde dans le cadre de la
négociation des prix des médicaments
avec l'industrie pharmaceutique il avait
pour objectif de réviser à la hausse le
montant m c'est-à-dire le montant de
chiffre d'affaires à partir duquel les
entreprises pharmaceutiques sont
assujettis à une contribution le montant
m est actuellement de 24,6 milliards
d'euros et le gouvernement propose de le
porter à
24,9 milliards d'euros au regard des
j'ouvre les guillemets à attente des
industriels du secteur du médicament je
ferme les guillemets selon l'exposé du
motif des motifs du projet de loi c'est
tout simplement un cadeau aux
entreprises les plus riches pourtant les
laboratoires étrangl littéralement la la
sécurité sociale depuis l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron en 2017 le chiffre
d'affaires des médicaments remboursé par
l'État a augmenté de plus de 16 % pour
atteindre 30,4 milliards d'euros en 2021
les laboratoires n'ont pas besoin de ce
cadeau en revanche la sécurité sociale a
besoin de cette contribution pour le
moins juste de la part des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques par ailleurs le
d'ailleurs surtout le rapport de nos
collègues Laurence Cohen et Sonia de la
provoté le rappeler la négociation des
prix du médicament entre les pouvoirs
publics et les grands laboratoires est
largement déséquilibré ne la
déséquilibrons pas plus notre amendement
est souten tenu par Médecin du Monde et
la Mutualité Française merci merci
amendement 887 madame
Brulin merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre c'est également un
amendement de suppression de cet article
4 parce qu'il ne nous semble en effet
pas pertinent de privé l'Assurance
Maladie de 120 millions d'euros dans le
contexte de déficit dont nous débattons
depuis un moment
maintenant d'autant que nous voyons
quelles sont les politiques de
l'industrie pharmaceutique et les
pénuries de médicaments qui se
développent on parle évidemment beaucoup
de l'amoxiciline mais on pourrait citer
d'autres
médicamament et pour l'instant les
dispositions prises ne corrigent
absolument pas ces pénuries dont je le
rappelle la commission d'enquête de
notre de nos collègues Laurence Cohen et
Sonia de la provoté vient d'être évoqué
elle a mis notamment en évidence qu'il y
avait en 2023 37 pour % de nos
concitoyens qui s'étaient dit confrontés
à ces pénuries de médicaments c'est
absolument énorme et nous pensons que
cette rectification du montant m de la
clause de sauvegarde est d'autant moins
pertinente que les industriels viennent
d'obtenir du ministère de la Santé une
augmentation de 10 % des tarifs et des
prix réglementés d'un certain nombre de
médicaments souscouvert de certaines
garanties qu'ils apporteraient et parmi
ces garanties il y a des choses que la
loi leur impose déjà comme par exemple
avoir un stock de 2 mois de médicaments
et donc on ne peut pas accepter dans le
contexte actuel que l'assurance maladie
se prive de ces 120 millions d'euros qui
va évidemment bénéficier à l'industrie
pharmaceutique laquelle ne met
absolument rien en œuvre pour
contrecarrer les pénuries auxquell nous
avons à faire face en ce
moment sur ces deux amendements
identiques la commission madame la
rapporteur générale oui merci monsieur
le Président donc ces deux amendements
proposent de supprimer cet article je
rappelle que cet article en fait il fixe
le montant m le montant m c'est le
montant que l'ensemble des médicaments
ne doivent pas dépasser sinon il est
appliqué une clause de sauvegarde
lorsque nous avons débattu en loi
d'approbation des comptes il y a pas si
longtemps on avait fait en fait un petit
comment rapport sur cette clause de
sauvegarde qui en fait devait être une
corde de rappel budgétaire et qui est
devenu en fait au fil du temps un vrai
objet fiscal quelque part et donc on
était monter dans des proportions qui
étaient très très importantes et donc
nous avions dit que les choses ne
pouvaient pas continuer comme comme cela
la première ministre a lancé une
opération avec des membres qualifiés qui
ont travaillé avec les industriels et
donc ils ont regardé comment les choses
pouvaient évoluer à l'avenir et donc ces
personnalités qualifiées ont donc donc
proposer pour l'instant que l'on
augmente ce prixm afin qu'il ne se
déclenche pas tout de suite pour les
industriels mais en l'occurrence il
continue à travailler sur justement ces
ces comment dire ces prix du médicament
parce qu'il faut pas oublier non plus
que aujourd'hui à cause du
vieillissement de la population à cause
des produits innovants qui coûtent très
très cher et bien le prix des
médicaments globalement a beaucoup
augmenté donc il faut aussi regarder
comment on peut en quelque sorte freiner
cette hausse très très importante et qui
ne fera que d'ailleurs de s'implifier
donc il faut absolument que les outils
budgétaires soit remanié et c'est ce que
font ces
personnalités qualifiées et donc là il y
a eu un New Deal qui a été conclu les
industriels sont d'accord et donc ce
montant a été euh augmenté c'est donc
pour cette raison que c'est un avis
défavorable pour la suppression de cet
article avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre merci Monsieur le le le
président quelques quelques quelques
remarques d'abord sur la question de la
régulation des des dépenses de de
médicaments on est on est pris entre
deux objectifs il faut le dire c'est
qu'à la fois pour offrir de nouveaux
traitements nous adapter à l'innovation
thérapeutique augmenter les chances
aussi dans les traitements s'adapter au
vieillissement démographique on a des
innovations qui coûtent plus cher et
d'un notre côté on doit réguler les les
dépenses de de médicaments donc on est
toujours pris effectivement entre ces
deux ces deux deux objectif je le
rappelle quand même parce qu'il a été
évoqué des augmentations de prix pour
l'année qui vient dans le PLFSS il y a
un effort sur les prix demandés aux
industriels de plus d'un milliard
d'euros donc c'est pas c'est quand je
parle des efforts partagés et je vais
venir sur la sur le M les efforts sont
effectivement partagés on demande aussi
aux industriel de de de contribuer
madame la rapporteur générale évoqué
effectivement le rapport qui s'appelle
le le pour un new deal avec des
personnalités d'horizon extrêmement
différentes qui nous a aidé notamment à
caler le dispositif de la de la clause
de la clause m et je rappelle d'ailleurs
que son montant ces dernières années n'a
eu de 16 de croître il était de 159
millions d'euros en 2019 780 millions
d'euros en 2021 et probablement qu'en
2022 il s'élèvera à 1 milliard à 1
milliard d'euros donc voilà on est
toujours partagé entre ces deux objectif
et je crois que la manière dont il a été
réglé pour cette année au regard d'un
travail conduit par des personnalités
extérieur je pense qu'on a trouvé le le
le bon équilibre enfin s'agissant des
des ruptures de de stock vous dire que
le bilan de de l'hiver dernier a été a
été tiré il y a un travail Aurélien
Rousseau l'évoquait encore cet
après-midi devant vous avec l'ensemble
l'ensemble des acteurs que des mesures
concrètes ont été prises sur une liste
de 450 médicaments essentiels qui font
suiv euh l'objet d'un suivi renforcé
pour prévenir les ruptures de stock et
que dans le PLFSS on a un certain nombre
de mesures notamment des mesures
d'épargne sur des médicaments en tension
d'approvisionnement la prescription à
l'unité ou bien euh les ordonnances avec
un conditionnement une condition
préalable avec notamment des tests ce
qu'on appelle les trodes avant avant
prescription voilà donc toutes ces ces
sujets répondent à une partie de vos
préoccupations et figure directement
dans le PLFSS donc pour toutes ces
raisons avis défavorable merci je vais
mettre au voix ces deux oui madame
apoursopoli pour explication de vote oui
monsieur le ministre j'entends hein ce
que vous dites que les entreprises
pharmaceutiques vont faire un geste d'un
milliard d'euros c'est bien ce que vous
avez ce que vous avez dit hein je tiens
quand même à à vous rappeler que les
cadeaux faits aux aux industries
pharmaceutiques pendant la crise 100 %
des des entreprises du CAC 40 ont
bénéficié des aides publiques de l'État
hein qui a un petit versement de 51
milliards d'euros à leur actionnaire qui
a été donc distribué par ces entreprises
et pourtant que 80 % d'entre elles elles
ont eu recours au chômage partiel et
puis je voudrais vous rappeler quand
même un exemple Sanofi bénéfice 125 à
130 millions d'euros par an par an hein
d'abattements fiscaux au titre du crédit
impôt recherche ça nous fit à supprimer
2000 emplois ces dernières années donc
quand vous nous parlez d'un milliard
pour l'ensemble des industries
pharmaceutique vous m'excuserez du peu
mais elles auraient pu mettre un peu
plus la main à la poche Monsieur
jaumier Merci monsieur le Président jeis
un des problèmes c'est quand même que le
mécanisme de la clause de sauvegarde est
particulièrement imprévisible et que il
ne permet pas une planification
financière stable en plus d'être être
indiscriminé et que d'ailleurs plusieurs
mesures qui permettent de tenir compte
par exemple de la CR criticité pardon
thérapeutique d'un médicament ou de la
sécurité d'approvisionnement du marché
français ne sont pas pris en compte dans
les critères légaux de la clause de
sauvegarde et c'est ça qui a été pointé
notamment dans le rapport de la
commission d'enquête du Sénat et c'est
pour ça que ce rapport demandait qu'il
fallait d'évaluer l' opportunité
d'exclure les médicaments critiques par
exemple de la clause de sauvegarde et de
mieux tenir compte des priorités de
santé publique parce que là on a une
clause de sauvegarde qui effectivement
en volume a considérablement progressé
il y a eu un bon en 2 ans de la
rentabilité de la clause de sauvegarde
et donc on entend les industriels dire
oh là là vous nous prélevez de plus en
plus mais ce mécanisme est en fait n'est
pas adapté alors on est très content du
New du je sais pas quoi et cetera mais
la réalité c'est que les critères
objectifs les critères objectifs qui
permettraient de l'améliorer ne sont
toujours pas mis sur la table et qu' a
une certaine opacité qui règne comme
souvent d'ailleurs malheureusement dans
le domaine du médicament et qui amène à
ce que on consacre des montants
considérables qui parfois sont tout à
fait nécessaires du fait du prix des
nouveaux médicaments et de l'innovation
thérapeutique mais qui d'autrefois ne
répondent pas au critères de santé
publique et au critères de disponibilité
qu'on est en droit de réclamer madame
Brulin j'ajoute aux arguments qui
viennent d'être développés qu'en effet
il y a un souci de manque de
transparence absolue sur la manière dont
sont construit ses prix des médicaments
effectivement ça peut
sembler logique que les médicaments
innovants coûtent beaucoup plus cher et
que ce soit prise en compte mais on voit
aussi qu'un certain nombre d'industriels
de l'industrie pharmaceutique
investissent dans ces nouveaux
médicaments ces médicaments innovants
qui leur permettent ensuite de dire que
ça a un coût important en abandonnant en
parallèle d'autres médicaments qui ne
sont plus jugés comme assez profitables
Sanofi vient par exemple d'annoncer
qu'elle allait tourner la page du
doliprane or ce sont précisément sur ces
médicaments plus matures mais qui sont
absolument indispensables pour nos
concitoyens que nous connaissons le plus
de pénurie et donc qu'il y ait besoin de
revoir un certain nombre de mécanismes
que la puissance publique se dote
d'outils pour réguler pour y compris
relocaliser parce qu'il est question il
il y a besoin aussi de relocaliser un
certain nombre de production en France
on a eu beaucoup de promesses en la
matière et pour l'instant assez peu de
résultats mais si ce travail est à
engager et si effectivement la
commission d'enquête a adressé un
certain nombre de pistes qui peuvent
nous le comprenons parfaitement prendre
un peu de temps à être travaillé il
n'empêche que ce privé de 120 millions
d'euros cette année dans le contexte que
chacun a pu décrire ici nous semble une
très très mauvaise idée madame Goulet
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre depuis le début de de la séance
de ce soir on jongle avec les millions
et les milliards c'est quand même un
climat un peu au doigts mouillés et moi
je voudrais revenir sur ce qui a été dit
sur sur les bands de nos collègues
communistes républicain citoyens et
kanaki en ce qui concerne un certain
nombre d'avantages et de sauvegarde des
des entreprises pharmaceutiques dont les
quatre plus grandes sont soumis à des
enquêtes pour fraude et évasion fiscale
à un très haut niveau je pense que
toutes ces dispositions devraient faire
l'objet d'un paquet et et au moins d'un
équilibre c'est-à-dire que ne pas avoir
de de de garantie si de l'autre côté on
n' pas de de garantie pour le
contribuable moi je crois que tout ça
devrait quand même être être aussi
repensé les les industries
pharmaceutiques ont échappé l'année
dernière à une taxe sur les super
profits alors que les les chiffres
avancés étaient quand même assez
extraordinaires il y a eu les aides
covid on l' on l'a rappelé tout à
l'heure moi je crois qu'il faudrait
monsieur le ministre travailler
globalement à la fois sur les apports
que le contribuable et l'État peut
donner pour garantir évidemment le
médicament et cetera mais que de l'autre
côté le contribuable soit aussi rassuré
en ce qui concerne le contrôle de
l'évasion et de la fraude fiscale je
crois que ce serait pour le coup un
équilibre tout à fait
justifié merci je vais mettre au vote
ces deux amendements qui ont identiques
qui ont reçu un double avis défavorable
de la commission et du gouvernement qui
est
pour qui est est contre qui s'abstient
ils ne sont pas
adoptés amendement
1187 madame Lubin
oui alors par cet amendement nous nous
souhaitons abaisser ce fameux montant m
en corrigeant celui voté en LFSS en
2023 depuis l'élection du Président de
la République en 2017 le chiffre
d'affaires des médicaments remboursés
par l'État augmenté de plus de 16 % pour
atteindre 30,4 milliards d'euros 2021 en
2021 toujours selon la journaliste
Rosine le 5 quatre premiers laboratoires
Novartis Bristol Myers squib merk
Johnson and Johnson ont concentré eux
seuls plus de 7 milliards versés par
l'assurance maladie les laboratoire
profitent de la sécurité sociale et
pendant ce temps le gouvernement abaisse
les montants rétrocédés au titre de la
clause de sauvegarde et pendant que les
grands laboratoires pharmaceutiques
engrangent des bénéfices les
établissements publics de santé sont on
pris à la gorge par l'inflation la
révision du montant m pour 2023 qui
tient compte des attentes des
industriels du secteur du médicament
c'est dans l'exposé des motifs ne
permettra pas de conquérir un accès égal
et durable des patients aux médicaments
le rapport dont de nos de nos rapport
sénatorial dont nos collègues ont déjà
beaucoup parlé confirme d'une part que
les pénuries ne sont pas causées par le
prix des médicaments et d'autre part la
négociation entre les pouvoirs publics
et les grands laboratoires est
structurellement déséquilibré les
menaces d'arrêt de commercialisation de
déremboursement ou de dénis d'accès
précocece sont des armes de choix entre
les mains des exploitant et ne
permettent pas de lutter contre la
hausse des pénuries il est temps de
changer de dogme en luttant pour la
transparence des prix du médicament et
l'institution d'une production publique
merci avis de la commission même la
rapporteur générale sur cet amendement
oui cet amendement propose en fait de
supprimer la disposition qui est
introduite par cet article donc ça
revient finalement au même par rapport
aux autres propositions que nous avons
vu tout à l'heure je voudrais d'ailleurs
répondre à notre collègue Brulin de tout
à l'heure qui disait par rapport au
médicaments génériques nous aurons à
l'article 11 la discussion le débat sur
ces éléments-là donc nous reviendrons
plus largement sur les comment les
inquiétudes qu'elle a exprimé tout à
l'heure en tout cas là c'est un avis
défavorable merci merci Monsieur le
Ministre avis du
gouvernement merci monsieur le Président
pour pour les mêmes raisons qu'exposé
précédemment et à la fois parce qu'on
s'appuie sur un rapport qui qui insiste
aussi sur la nécessité d'encourager les
industriels dans l'innovation
thérapeutique notamment et de l'autre
parce qu'on demande un effort sur les
prix d'un milliard d'euros dans le PLFSS
2024 c'est donc un avis
défavorable merci je vais donc mettre au
vote cet amendement avec un double avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
amendement 188 de la commission madame
la rapporteur
générale alors ce que nous venons de de
voter pour le montant m nous proposons
de le faire sur le montant Z qui
concerne du coup les dispositifs
médicaux et nous porterions ce seuil de
déclenchement de la clause de sauvegarde
des dispositifs médicaux pour l'année
2023 de 2000 de 2
milliards 21 à 2 mliard 35 pour
justement cette année le niveau de
fixation du montant Z ne permet pas en
effet de tenir compte de la croissance
conjoncturelle du secteur qui suit une
période de contraction du chiffre
d'affaires des entreprises concernées
intervenu pendant la crise sanitaire les
représentants du secteur indiquent
craindre en outre un déclenchement donc
de la clause de sauvegarde pour des
montants importants en 2023 comme en
2024 compte tenu de ces incertitudes
importantes et dans la mesure où le
secteur des dispositifs médicaux est
très hétérogène et constitué de
nombreuses petites et moyennes
entreprises fournissant un système de
santé euh au système de santé des
produits essentiels à la prise en charge
des patients il apparaît nécessaire de
réhausser le montant Z pour
2023 merci avis du gouvernement monsieur
le ministre merci Monsieur le le
président sur sur cet amendement de de
la
Commission plutôt un avis défavorable
pour pour quelle raison on a on a calé
le montant de de la clause de sauvegarde
du montant Z en fonction de notre
ambition au regard de l'enjeu industriel
notamment France 2030 mais aussi on a
tenu compte du fait que les engagements
de de de baisse de prix des dispositifs
médicaux n'ont pas été tenus par les
industriel et là aussi c'est un choix
d'équilibre entre ces deux dimensions
c'est-à-dire quand on on demande aux
industriels de s'engager sur des baisses
de prix on souhaite qu'il les respectent
et d'autre part on souhaite aussi
encourager un secteur industriel donc
c'est ce montant là résulte de C de cet
équilibre que nous avons trouvé nous
souhaitons pas changer cet équilibre là
donc c'est un avis c'est un avis
défavorable si je vais mettre au voix
cet amendement de la commission avec un
avis défavorable du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté je vais
mettre au voie l'article 4 mes chers
collègues qui est pour l'article
4 qui est contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté après l'article 4 je suis saisi
de qure amendements faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune amendement 105
rectifié monsieur burgois oui merci
monsieur le Président cet amend vise à
réduire le tx de la contribution sur les
ventes en gros à 1 % afin de dégager des
moyens pour permettre aux entreprises de
la répartition pharmaceutique de relever
la tête et de palier en partie les
difficultés du secteur il s'agit d'une
mesure essentiell pour sécuriser ce
maillon indispensable de la chaîne de
médicaments en France et seul secteur en
mesure de livrer quotidiennement tous
les Médicam dans des conditions
optimales au 21000 pharmacies françaises
sur l'ensemble du territoire jusque dans
les zones les plus difficiles d'accès
mais aussi dans les déserts médicaux où
les pharmacies sont souvent le dernier
acteur de santé accessible merci
amendement identique le
380 rectifié quat qu'il présente
monsieur
Belin merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président de la Commission
madame la rapporteur monsieur le
ministre j'ai pas voulu allonger le
débat tout à l'heure monsieur le
ministre mais je crois qu'on pourra pas
faire l'économie à un moment donné
devant le Parlement d'un débat sur le
médicament il y a eu plein de choses de
censé de dites ce soir mais à un moment
donné la question du médicament é
essentielle pour le patient vous avez
parlé de médicament essentiel un
médicament est essentiel pour un patient
donné et aujourd'hui je peux vous
assurer qu'il y a encore plus de
manquant qu'il n'y avait avant qu'il y
ait cette commission d'enquête
parlementaire le sujet aujourd'hui qui
est abordé par cet amendement sur la
contribution de ce qu'on appelle les
répartiteurs il est essentiel aussi
parce qu'il rime avec le maintien d'un
dispositif qui concourt à l'aménagement
du territoire car aujourd'hui la moindre
officine rurale peut délivrer toute
spécialité même dans la journée le matin
pour le soir ou le soir pour le
lendemain matin et donc c'est répar